Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this work, a 121-layer convolutional neural
network is trained to recognize pneumonia
and 13 different diseases.
Pneumonia is an inflammatory lung condition
that is responsible for a million hospitalizations
and 50,000 deaths per year in the US alone.
Such an algorithm requires a training set
of formidable size to work properly.
This means a bunch of input-output pairs.
In this case, one training sample is an input
frontal X-ray image of the chest, and the
outputs are annotations by experts who mark
which of the 14 different sought diseases
are present in this sample.
So they say like this image contains pneumonia
here, and this doesn't.
This is not just a binary yes or no answer,
but a more detailed heatmap of possible regions
that fit the diagnosis.
The training set used for this algorithm contained
over a 100.000 images of over 30.000 patients.
This is then given to the neural network,
and its task is to learn the properties of
these diseases by itself.
Then, after the learning process took place,
previously unseen images are given to the
algorithm and a set of radiologists.
This is called a test set, and of course,
it is crucial that both the training and the
test sets are reliable.
If the training and test set is created by
one expert radiologist, and then we again
benchmark a neural network against a different,
randomly picked radiologist, that's not a
very reliable process because each of the
humans may be wrong in more than a few cases.
Instead, the training and test annotation
data is created by asking multiple radiologists
and taking a majority vote on their decisions.
So now that the training and test data is
reliable, we can properly benchmark a human
versus a neural network.
And here's the result: this learning algorithm
outperforms the average human radiologist.
The performance was measured in a 2D space,
where sensitivity and specificity were the
two interesting metrics.
Sensitivity means the proportion of positive
samples that were classified as positive,
and specificity means the portion of negative
samples that were classified as negative.
The crosses mean the human doctors, and as
you can see, whichever radiologist we look
at, even though they have different false
positive and negative ratios, they are all
located below the blue curve which denotes
the results of the learning algorithm.
This is a simple diagram, but if you think
about what it actually means, this is an incredible
application of machine intelligence.
And now, a word on limitations.
It is noted that this was an isolated test,
for instance, the radiologists were only given
one image, and usually, when diagnosing someone,
they know more about the history of the patient
that may further help their decisions.
For instance, a history of a strong cough
and high fever is highly useful supplementary
information for humans when diagnosing someone
who may have pneumonia.
Beyond only the frontal view of the chest,
it is also standard practice to use the lateral
views as well if the results are inconclusive.
These views are not available in this dataset
and it is conjectured that it may sway the
comparison towards humans.
However, I'll note that this information may
also benefit the AI just as much as the radiologists,
and this seems like a suitable direction for
future work.
Finally, this is not the only algorithm for
pneumonia detection, and it has been compared
to the state of the art for all 14 diseases,
and this new technique came out on top on
all of them.
Also, have a look at the paper for details
because training a 121-layer neural network
requires some clever shenanigans as this was
the case here too.
It is really delightful to see that these
learning algorithms can help diagnosing serious
illnesses, and provide higher quality healthcare
to more and more people around the world,
especially in places where access to expert
radiologists is limited.
Everyone needs to hear about this.
If you wish to help us spreading the word
and telling these incredible stories to even
more people, please consider supporting us
on Patreon.
We also know that many of you are crazy for
Bitcoin, so we also set up a Bitcoin address
as well.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!